This is an I-Heart podcast. Guaranteed Human. Hey, what's good, y'all? You're listening to Learn the Hardway with your favorite therapist and host Kear Games. This space is about black men's experiences, having honest conversations that it's really not safe to have anywhere, but you're having them with a licensed professional who knows what he's doing. How many men carry a suit or armor. It signals to the world that you not to be played with. And just because you have the capability that does not mean that you need to.
这是一个I-Heart播客。真人真事，如假包换。嘿，大家好，最近怎么样？欢迎收听由你最喜欢的治疗师兼主持人凯尔·盖恩斯（Kear Games）为你带来的《以硬核方式去学习》（Learn the Hardway）。这个空间旨在探讨黑人男性的经历，进行那些在其他任何地方进行都不太安全的坦诚对话，但在这里，你是在和一个懂行的执照专业人士交流。有多少男人背负着一套盔甲。它向世界发出信号：你可不是好惹的。但这并不意味着只要你有这个能力，就非得这么做。
Listen to learn the hard way on the AHA radio app, Apple Podcast, or wherever you get your podcast. In 2023, Bachelor star Clayton Eckerd was accused of fathering twins. But the pregnancy appeared to be a hoax. You doctored this particular test twice in someone, correct? I doctored the test ones. It took an army of internet detectives to uncover a disturbing pattern. Two more men who'd been through the same thing. Greg, a lesbian.
在AHA广播应用、苹果播客或你获取播客的任何平台上收听《以硬核方式去学习》。2023年， 《单身汉》明星克莱顿·埃克德（Clayton Eckerd）被指控是双胞胎的生父。但这场怀孕似乎是一场骗局。你曾两次篡改了这个特定的测试，对吗？我篡改过一次测试。这动用了大批网络侦探，才揭露出一个令人不安的模式。另外两个经历过同样事情的男士。格雷格，一个女同性恋。
Michael Mancini. My mind was blown. I'm Stephanie Young. This is Love Trapped. Laura, Scottsdale Police. As the season continues, Laura Owens finally faces consequences. Listen to Love Trapped podcast on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. 2%. That's the number of people who take the stairs when there is also an escalator available. I'm Michael Easter.
迈克尔·曼奇尼。我的脑洞大开。我是斯蒂芬妮·杨。这是《爱情陷阱》。劳拉，斯科茨代尔警察。随着节目的继续，劳拉·欧文斯终于面临了后果。在IHeart Radio应用、苹果播客或你获取播客的任何地方收听《爱情陷阱》播客。2%。这就是当有自动扶梯可用时，仍然选择走楼梯的人的比例。我是迈克尔·伊斯特。
And on my podcast, 2%. I break down the science of mental toughness, fitness, and building resilience in our strange modern. and worry. Put yourself through some hardships and you will come out on the other side a happier, more fulfilled, healthier person. Listen to 2%. That's TWO percent on the IHeartRadio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. When a group of women discover they've all dated the same prolific con artist, they take matters into their own hands. I vowed. I will be his last target. He is not going to get away with this. He's going to get what he deserves. We always say trust your girlfriends. Listen to the girlfriends. Trust me, babe, on the Iheart radio app,
在我的播客《2%》中，我将剖析精神坚韧度、体能训练以及在我们这个奇怪的现代世界中建立韧性的科学。与焦虑作斗争。经历一些艰难困苦，你就会在另一端成为一个更快乐、更充实、更健康的人。在IHeartRadio应用、苹果播客或你获取播客的任何地方收听《2%》。这就是T-W-O（两个）百分之。当一群女性发现她们都曾与同一个多产的骗子约过后，她们决定自己采取行动。我发誓。我将成为他最后一个目标。他休想就这么逃脱。他会得到应有的下场。我们总是说，相信你的女性朋友。收听《女性朋友》。相信我，宝贝，在IHeart Radio应用上，
Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Hello everybody and welcome back to the psychology of your 20s, the podcast where we talk through some of the big life changes and transitions of our 20s and what they mean for our psychology. Hello everybody. Welcome back to the show. Welcome back to the podcast. New listeners, old listeners, wherever you are in the world, it is so great to have you here back for another episode as we of course break down the psychology of our 20s. So there seems to be this like implicit, unspoken rush, this unspoken timeline during our 20s. We're going to be this unspoken timeline during our 20s. 20s to find love to have found your soulmate, found the love of your life by the time you turn 30.
苹果播客，或任何你收听播客的地方。大家好，欢迎回到《你二十多岁的心理学》，在这个播客里，我们探讨二十多岁时的一些重大生活变化与过渡，以及它们对我们心理意味着什么。大家好。欢迎回到节目。欢迎回到播客。新听友，老听友，无论你身在世界的哪个角落，很高兴你能来到这里，收听我们的又一期节目，当然，我们一直在剖析二十多岁的心理。所以，在我们的二十多岁，似乎有一种隐性的、心照不宣的急迫感，一种心照不宣的时间表。我们要在二十多岁时，有一种心照不宣的时间表。在三十岁生日到来之前，去找到爱，找到你的灵魂伴侣，找到你一生的挚爱。
It may not be said out loud. Your family may not be saying it. Your friends may not be saying it. Society may not be outwardly saying it. But it very much does feel like if you are getting closer to 30, if you're moving through your 20s and you haven't had many dating experiences, you haven't had much luck, you haven't found the one that you are in some ways falling behind. And that can lead to a lot of us going on as many dates as possible, really feeling the rush
这话可能不会大声说出来。你的家人可能没这么说。你的朋友可能没这么说。社会可能没有表面上这么说。但这种感觉确实非常强烈：如果你正在逼近三十岁，如果你正在经历二十多岁，却没有过多少约会经历，没有多少运气，没有找到那个对的人，你在某些方面就是在落后。这可能会导致我们中的许多人尽可能多地去约会，真正感受到那种急迫感。
to find someone, feeling like dating is in many ways a numbers game. We really, really want to have that person in our lives who we can trust, who we're monogamous with, who we're committed to, who we can grow with. And in order to do that, we're kind of going to have to maybe kiss a lot of frogs, see a lot of people, spend a lot of time on the dating app, swiping, and matching and going on lousy first dates, going on incredible first dates, then getting ghosted. It can be incredibly overwhelming. And it can lead to something called dating burnout or dating fatigue.
去寻找某个人，觉得约会在很多方面就像是一场数字游戏。我们非常、非常希望在生活中拥有这样一个人：我们可以信任他，与他保持一夫一妻制，对彼此忠诚，并能一同成长。为了做到这一点，我们可能不得不去亲吻许多青蛙，见许多人，花大量时间在约会软件上刷资料、配对，经历糟糕的第一次约会，经历美妙的第一次约会，然后被“断崖式分手”（ghosting）。这可能会让人感到无比的压倒性。它可能会导致所谓的约会倦怠或约会疲劳。
And that is exactly what I want to talk about today. What happens when for a long time, for a very extended period of time, you have just found yourself in a pattern of bad dates, of feeling like everyone is disappointed. you, everyone is letting you down, no one is standing out, the ups aren't providing, and yet you're still putting yourself out there as much as possible with no reward. To put it quite simply, I think it feels firstly exhausting, but quite unfair when you are giving your everything to dating and it's not giving anything back to you. What I really want to discuss is what is the mental, psychological, emotional impacts and consequences of feeling like you have to continue to put yourself
而这正是我想在今天讨论的内容。当你在很长一段时间里、在一个非常长的周期内，发现自己陷入了这样一种模式：糟糕的约会、觉得每个人都让你失望、每个人都让你扫兴、没有人脱颖而出、那些高潮时刻并没有带来什么，然而你却仍然在尽最大可能地推销自己却没有任何回报，这时会发生什么？简单来说，我认为首先这会让人筋疲力尽，而且当你为约会付出了一切却没有得到任何回报时，这很不公平。我真正想讨论的是，当你觉得必须继续让自己经历这一切时，其心理、精神和情感上的影响和后果是什么？
through the dating ringer in order to find love, even when dating is absolutely and completely exhausting you. How do dating apps contribute to this? You know, one study from 2019, which actually examined the impacts of dating apps on our mental health, put it really well. there is this paradox in modern dating, wherein online platforms provide more opportunities than ever to find a romantic partner. But we are, you know, nonetheless, still more single than I think we've ever been because of just the extreme choice overload that we see with dating apps
通过约会来寻找真爱，即使约会已经让你彻底且完全精疲力竭。约会软件是如何助长这一现象的？你知道，2019年的一项研究很好地说明了这一点，该研究实际上考察了约会软件对我们心理健康的影响。现代约会中存在这样一个悖论：在线平台提供了比以往更多的机会来寻找浪漫伴侣。然而，我们却依然比以往任何时候都更加单身，这正是因为我们在约会软件上看到了极端的选择过载。
where it feels very abundant. And we could go on a date every single day if you really, really tried. But going on more dates is not necessarily, getting us closer to finding the one. And that is where that fatigue really sets in. You know, if you spend countless hours over time at work, pushing towards a goal and you never achieve it, you will be burnt out. If you spend hours at the gym working and pushing yourself, you will be fatigued. If you spend hours and hours with a friend who, you know, you don't really connect with any more, but you are forced to really chat to and talk to, you will experience
那种感觉选择非常丰富。如果你真的努力了，你甚至可以每天都去约会。但去更多的约会并不一定能让我们更接近找到那个对的人。这就是疲劳真正开始产生的时候。你知道，如果你在工作中花无数时间朝着一个目标努力却从未实现，你就会精疲力竭。如果你在健身房花时间锻炼和鞭策自己，你就会感到疲惫。如果你和一个你觉得自己已经不再有真正共鸣、但又不得不应付和交谈的朋友花上大把大把的时间，你就会经历……
the same thing that we experience when we date for too long with little success and little reward and feel like all of our cognitive, mental, even physical resources are going towards this project almost that we, no matter how hard we work, we're not any closer to finishing. That is really, I think, at the crux and at the foundation of why dating burnout, affects so many single people in their 20s. With so many other things in our lives, the harder you work, the more payout you get. The harder you push yourself in your career or in your studies or physically or emotionally or in terms of your hobbies. Like the harder you push yourself, the harder you work, the more time you commit, the better you get, the better the outcome. And dating is not the same.
我们经历的正是我们在约会太久却收效甚微、回报甚少时所经历的状况，并且感觉我们所有的认知、精神甚至身体资源都投入到了这个项目中，无论我们多么努力，我们离完成它都没有更近一步。我认为这确实是为什么约会倦怠会影响那么多二十多岁单身人士的核心和基础。对于我们生活中的许多其他事情，你工作越努力，你得到的回报就越多。你在职业、学业、身体、情感或爱好上越逼自己。就像你越鞭策自己，你越努力，你投入的时间越多，你就会变得越好，结果就越好。而约会则不同。
It is not the same type of game. I've heard from so many of you. you just lamenting at the fact that you never think you're going to find someone, you are completely and utterly dejected and rejected by the modern dating world. And I want to talk about it. I want to talk about why that happens, the impact, and the signs that maybe it's time to take a break. I also want to talk about my own experience when I was single and I was dating and how absolutely frustrated I was with dating for a period of time. And I took a break. I took a six-month break. I did a complete detox, which felt so kind of contrasting to what I really wanted, like I wanted to find love. Why would I take a break? Well, actually, it ended up completely
它不是同一种游戏。我听许多人向我倾诉。你们只是在哀叹，认为自己永远不会找到人，被现代约会世界彻底、完全地拒绝和抛弃了。我想谈谈这个。我想谈谈为什么会发生这种情况，它的影响，以及也许是时候休息一下的信号。我还想谈谈我单身和约会时的亲身经历，以及我在一段时间内对约会感到多么绝对的沮丧。然后我休息了。我休假了六个月。我做了一次彻底的排毒，这跟我真正想要的东西形成了鲜明的对比，就像我想要找到真爱一样。我为什么要休息？好吧，事实上，它最终彻底……
resetting my perspective on dating. It ended up improving my resilience, improving my self-reliance and my self-esteem. And it meant that when I went back out there, I actually met someone wonderful. So hopefully you can learn from my experience. I want to teach you exactly how you can counteract dating burnout in the most counterintuitive ways, along with so much more. So if this is something that you are experiencing, as we always say, you are not alone. This is a very common phenomenon at the moment. The dating world and the dating pool is very limited and very shallow. So how can you find your way through? What do you need to know? And so much more. So without further ado, let's get into navigating dating, burnout in our 20s.
重置了我对约会的看法。它最终提高了我的韧性、自立能力和自尊心。这意味着当我重新回到那里时，我真的遇到一个很棒的人。所以希望你能从我的经历中吸取教训。我想教你如何以最反直觉的方式抵消约会倦怠，以及更多内容。因此，如果你正在经历这种情况，正如我们常说的那样，你并不孤单。目前这是一个非常普遍的现象。约会世界和约会池非常有限且非常浅。那么你该如何找到出路呢？你需要知道什么？还有更多。废话不多说，让我们开始探讨如何应对我们二十多岁的约会倦怠。
2%. That is the number of people who take the stairs when there is also an escalator available. I'm Michael Easter. And on my podcast, 2%, I break down the science of mental toughness, fitness, and building resilience in our strange modern world. I'll be speaking with writers, researchers, and other health and fitness experts, and more to look past the impractical and way too complex pseudoscience that dominates the wellness industry. We really believe that seed oils were inherently inflammatory.
2%。这就是当有自动扶梯可用时，仍然选择走楼梯的人的比例。我是迈克尔·伊斯特。在我的播客《2%》中，我将剖析精神坚韧度、体能训练以及在我们这个奇怪的现代世界中建立韧性的科学。我将与作家、研究人员以及其他健康和健身专家等进行对话，看透主导健康产业的不切实际且过于复杂的伪科学。我们真的相信种子油本质上会引起炎症。
We got it wrong. Many of the problems that we are freaked out about in the world are the result of stress. Put yourself through some hardships, and you will come out on the other side a happier, more fulfilled, healthier person. Listen to 2%. That's T-W-O-P-P-Sent on the I-Hart Radio. app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Do you remember when Diana Ross double-tap Little Kim's boobs at the VMAs? Or when Kanye said that George Bush didn't like black people. I know what you're thinking.
我们弄错了。我们在世界上惊慌失措的许多问题都是压力的结果。经历一些艰难困苦，你就会在另一端成为一个更快乐、更充实、更健康的人。在I-Hart无线电应用、苹果播客或任何你获取播客的地方收听《2%》。名字叫T-W-O-P-P-Sent。你还记得黛安娜·罗斯在VMA颁奖典礼上双击小金（Lil' Kim）的胸部吗？或者当坎耶说乔治·布什不关心黑人时。我知道你在想什么。
What the hell does George Bush got to do with Little Kim? Well, you can find out on the Look Back at It podcast. I'm Sam Jette. And I'm Alex English. Each episode, we pick a here, unpack what went down, and try to make sense of how we survived it. Including a recent episode with Mark Lamont Hill, waxing all. all about crack in the 80s. To be clear, 84 is big to me, not just because of crack.
乔治·布什跟小金到底有什么关系？好吧，你可以在《回味过去》（Look Back at It）播客中找到答案。我是萨姆·杰特。我是亚历克斯·英格lish。每一集，我们都会挑选一个年份，剖析发生了什么，并试图理解我们是如何熬过这段经历的。包括最近一集与马克·拉蒙特·希尔（Mark Lamont Hill）的访谈，畅谈80年代的霹雳可卡因。坦白讲，84对我来说意义重大，不仅仅是因为霹雳可卡因。
I'm down to talk about crack all day, but just so you all know. I mean, at this point, Mark, this is the second episode where we've discussed crack. So I'm starting to see that there's a through line. We also have AIDS on the table right now. Thank you for finishing that sentence. I don't think there's a more important year for black people. Really? Yeah.
我随时都可以谈论霹雳可卡因，只是想让你们都知道。我的意思是，马克，这已经是我们讨论霹雳可卡因的第二集了。所以我开始看出其中有一条贯穿始终的主线。我们现在还把艾滋病摆在了台面上。谢谢你把话说完。我不认为对黑人来说还有比这更重要的年份了。真的吗？是的。
For me, it's one of the most important years for black people in American history. Listen to look back at it on the IHeartRadio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Welcome to my new podcast, Learn the Hardway with me, your host, and your favorite therapist, Keer Games. And in recognition of Mental Health Awareness Month, I'm bringing over a decade of my own experience in the mental health field and conversations with so many incredible guests. I'm talking. Trip Fontaine, Ryan Clark.
对我来说，这是美国历史上对黑人而言最重要的年份之一。在IHeartRadio应用、苹果播客或你获取播客的任何地方收听《Look Back at It》。欢迎来到我的新播客《以硬核方式去学习》，我是你的主持人、你最喜欢的治疗师凯尔·盖恩斯。为了庆祝心理健康意识月，我带来了自己在心理健康领域十多年的经验，以及与众多杰出嘉宾的对话。我说的是。特里普·方丹，瑞安·克拉克。
Sometimes when we're in the pursuit of the thing, we get so wrapped up in the chase that we don't realize that we are in possession of the thing and we're still chasing it and we don't know when we've done enough because people scoreboard watch. Life becomes about wins and losses. Steve Burns, Dustin Ross because you find it important
有时，当我们追求某样东西时，我们太过于沉迷于追逐本身，以至于没有意识到我们其实已经拥有了它，却还在继续追逐，并且不知道什么时候才算足够，因为人们都在盯着记分牌。生活变成了关于输赢的较量。史蒂夫·伯恩斯，达斯汀·罗斯，因为你觉得在世期间做一个好人很重要。还是你做一个好人是因为你害怕？因为那是两种不同的动机，兄弟。绝对是。
to be a good person while you hear on earth or are you a good person because you're afraid? Because that's two different intentions, bro. Absolutely. And that's two different levels of trust. I want you to just really be a good person. Join me, Kear Gaines, is we have real conversations about healing,
那是两个不同层面的信任。我希望你能够真正地做一个好人。加入我凯尔·盖恩斯的行列，我们在我的新播客《以硬核方式去学习》中，就疗愈、成长、父爱、压力和目标展开真实的对话。打开你免费的iHeartRadio应用。搜索《Learn the Hardway》并立即收听。2023年，前《单身汉》明星克莱顿·埃克德发现自己处于父权丑闻的中心。随后的家庭法庭听证会揭露了她故事中显而易见的矛盾之处。这引发了一场长达数年的法庭之战来证明真相。森女士，你曾两次篡改了这个特定的测试，对吗？我篡改了一次测试。这花费了一支网络侦探大队才破了案。
growth, fatherhood, pressure, purpose on my new podcast, Learn the Hardway. Open your free iHeartRadio app. Search Learn the Hardway and listen now. In 2023, former bachelor star Clayton Eckerd found himself at the center of a paternity scandal. The family court hearings that followed revealed glaring inconsistencies in her story. This began a years-long court battle to prove the truth. You doctored this particular test twice, Ms. Sond's, correct? I doctored the test once. It took an army of internet detectives to crack the case.
我想让人们能够看到他们的纳税被用在了什么地方。阳光是最好的消毒剂。他们将揭露一个令人不安的模式。另外两个经历过同样事情的男士。格雷格·莱斯皮安和迈克尔·马拉蒂尼。我的大脑都要炸了。
I wanted people to be able to see what their tax dollars were being used for. Sunlight's the greatest disinfected. They would uncover a disturbing pattern. Two more men who'd been through the same thing. Greg Lespian and Michael Marantini. My mind was blown.
我是斯蒂芬妮·杨。这是《爱情陷阱》。劳拉，斯科茨代尔警察。随着节目的继续，劳拉·欧文斯终于面临了后果。女士们先生们，马里科帕县传来突发新闻，劳拉·欧文斯已被指控犯有欺诈罪。在亚利桑那州伸张正义之前，这一切都不会结束。在Iheart Radio应用、苹果播客或任何你获取播客的地方收听《爱情陷阱》播客。
I'm Stephanie Young. This is Love Trap. Laura, Scottsdale Police. As the season continues, Laura Owens finally faces consequences. Ladies and gentlemen, breaking news at Americopa County as Laura Owens has been indicted on fraud charges. This isn't over until justice is served in Arizona. Listen to Love Trapped Podcast on the Iheart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts.
我想从一个可能会吓到你、也可能会鼓励你的统计数据开始。我希望它能给你带来一种安慰感，甚至也许能在你们这些单身同胞之间建立起一种社群感。几年前（2022年）做的一项研究采访了一群年龄在18岁到54岁之间、目前正在积极约会的成年人。结果发现，其中78%的人正在经历约会倦怠，另外80%的人表示这专门与在线约会有关系。还有54%的人表示他们已经对在约会软件上找到伴侣失去了希望，28%的人表示他们对永远找到伴侣失去了希望。所以，对于这样一个巨大、复杂但又普遍的心理现象，有趣的是我们并没有更多地谈论它。
I want to begin with a statistic that might scare you, might encourage you. I hope it brings you a sense of comfort and maybe even community between your fellow single people. A study done a couple of years ago, 2022, interviewed a bunch of adults between the age of 18 and 54 who were actively and currently dating. And it found that 78% of them were experiencing dating burnout, with a further 80% of them saying that that was specifically to do with online dating. A further 54% said that they had lost hope in ever finding someone on the dating apps. and 28% said they lost hope in ever finding someone ever. So, for such a big, complicated but also common mental phenomena, it's interesting that we don't talk about it more.
约会倦怠到底是什么感觉？嗯，我本来想说，它看起来是什么样的？但我确实认为这真是一种感觉。这是一种直觉。这是对某种情况和某种经历的直觉反应。在这种经历中，约会不再给你带来任何快乐或满足感。它不再令人兴奋。它并不像本该那般有趣。你会觉得约会是一种杂务，就像你每周必须做的事一样，你知道，去杂货店买菜，洗床单，打扫房子，和Hinge上的比尔约会，
What exactly does dating burnout actually feel like? Well, I was going to say, what does it look like? But I do actually think that it is truly a feeling. It's a gut feeling. It's a gut reaction to a situation and to an experience. experience whereby dating is not giving you any more joy or satisfaction. It's not exciting. It's not fun as it's meant to be. You will feel like dating is a chore, like it's something you have to do each week, you know, go grocery shopping, clean my bed sheets, clean my house, go on a date with Bill from Hinge,
和两到三个人约会以保持我的数字，因为，你知道，也许最终这个人就是那个对的人。当你滑动屏幕、结识新朋友时，你常常会感到筋疲力尽和绝望。有一个有趣的现象是，很多时候你已经在预料事情会变糟糕。你已经预料到他们会拒绝你。在某些情况下，你甚至有点希望他们这么做。你希望他们取消约会，因为你实在承受不起又一次破灭的希望。你承受不起另一种失败的处境，另一种“差点成功”的境地。我想回到这种感觉：当你结识新朋友、滑动屏幕时……
go on a date with two to three people to keep my numbers up because, you know, maybe eventually this person will be the one. You often feel exhausted and hopeless when you, you know, you're you're swiping, when you're meeting new people. There is this interesting experience where a lot of the time you're already anticipating that it's going to go badly. You're already anticipating that they will reject you. In some situations, you even kind of hope that they do. You hope that they cancel because you just cannot take another failed moment of hope. You cannot take another failed situation, another almost their kind of situation. I want to return to this idea of feeling like when you're meeting new people when you're swiping
你甚至懒得去理会，因为你已经预料到他们会拒绝你。这其实是一种被称为“拒绝心态”的心态。根据Hinge最近的一项研究发现，我们许多积极约会的人最终都会有这种感觉。这让我们感到特别疲惫，觉得约会池特别缺乏任何希望。因此，拒绝心态基本上意味着我们主要关注我们所经历的所有拒绝，并开始相信这种拒绝模式会跟随我们进入未来。所以我们开始期待，每当我们遇到一个新朋友时，结果都会很糟糕。那些曾经发生过这种情况的场景确实是最先浮现在我们脑海中的。
that you can't even be bothered because you already anticipate that they're going to reject you. This is actually a mindset known as the rejection mindset. And according to a recent study by Hinge, it found that a lot of us who are actively dating end up feeling this way. And it makes us feel particularly exhausted and like the dating pool is particularly lacking of any promise. So a rejection mindset, it basically means that we focus primarily on all the rejections that we've had and we start to believe that those, that pattern of rejection is going to follow us into the future. So we come to expect that whenever we need a new person, it's going to end up poorly. Those situations where it has before are really the first to come up
这最终会导致什么？嗯，它几乎意味着我们首先拒绝了自己，因为被拒绝实在是太痛苦了，特别是在浪漫关系中，如果拒绝来自我们自己，如果我们把自己从游戏中抽离出来，我们会觉得我们在把痛苦降到最低。它还会渗透到我们真正出现并展现自我时的状态中。比如，你在进行一次极好的约会。进展非常顺利。有激情、有火花、有契合度。对话就像黄油和液体一样顺畅。这是一次美妙的约会。在你的潜意识里，你可能会想：好吧，别太投入。在这里克制一下。勒住缰绳。不要展现最好的自己。不要在这上面倾注太多精力，因为结局会和以前完全一样……
in our memories. What does this end up doing? Well, it almost ends up meaning that we reject ourselves first because it's just so painful to be dismissed, especially romantically, that if it's coming from us, if we take ourselves out of the game, we feel like we are minimizing the pain. It can also bleed into how we are when we do show up and we are present. So say, for example, you're on an amazing date. It's going so well. There's passion, this spark, this compatibility. The conversation is like buttery and smooth and liquid. It's just beautiful, a beautiful date. In the back, of your mind, you might be thinking, all right, don't get too attached. Hold back here. Hold the horses. Don't put your best self forward. Don't put too much energy into this because it's going to end exactly
像所有过去的一样。这确实会让我们封闭自己，对吧？很自然地，这会让我们封闭自己，因为当你习惯了高度的脆弱并允许别人进入你的生活、敞开你博大的胸怀时，如果你经历了大量的约会倦怠或拒绝，你很快就会知道，那是受伤最简单的方式。这其实挺悲哀的，我们的约会经历几乎可以改变我们的性格以及我们对爱的开放程度。2019年有一项非常有趣的研究探讨了这一点。具体来说，它研究了拒绝心态和约会软件。
like all the last ones. And that can really close us off, right? Naturally, it's going to close us off because when you are used to being so intensely vulnerable and allowing people to come into your life, having that big open heart, if you are experiencing a great deal of dating burnout or rejection, you're going to pretty soon, you know, learn that that is the easiest way to be hurt. It's quite sad, really, how our dating experiences can almost change our personality and how open we are to love. There was this really interesting study that looked into this back in 2019. Specifically, it looked into the rejection mindset and dating apps.
他们的做法是将人们置于一个虚构的约会软件情境中。所以这些研究人员字面意义上真正地重新创造、制作了自己的约会软件，他们让人们在虚构的个人资料上滑动，决定他们想和谁约会，他们想和谁约会，他们要拒绝谁还是接受谁。他们还有另一个条件，这是在现实生活中，参与者有机会见到所有这些优秀的人，他们被告知所有人其实都已经喜欢你了。他们已经想和你约会了。他们已经说过他们被你吸引了。这就是他们来这里的原因。他们发现，参与者在软件上时会立即拒绝……
And what they did was they put people in a fake dating app scenario. So these researchers literally really. recreated, made their own dating app, and they asked people to swipe on fake profiles and decide who they wanted to date, who they would like to date, who they were going to reject versus accept. They also had another condition, and this was in real life, and the participants got to meet all these amazing people, and they were told all of these people already like you. They already want to go on a date with you. They've already said that they're attracted to you. That's why they're here. What they found was that the participants immediately when they were on the apps rejected
更多的人，因为他们预计如果他们与对方匹配、向对方右滑、对对方说是，无论如何他们还是会被拒绝，所以他们把自己退出了游戏，尽管没有任何信息表明情况确实如此。而在另一种情况下，当每个人都已被确认为可供选择时，拒绝率下降了27%。由于在线约会的性质以及我们如何基于我们自己的视角或心态去预测其他人的反应，结果证明我们往往会更多地拒绝自己，并自然而然地将自己排除在约会之外。
a whole lot more people expecting that if they were to, you know, match with them, swipe yes on them, say yes to them, they would be rejected anyway so they took themselves out of the game, despite, despite not having any information to indicate that that was the case. Whereas in the other condition, when everyone was already confirmed to be available, to them, the level of rejection decreased by 27%. Because of the kind of nature of online dating and how we anticipate other people's responses based on our own perspective or mindset, it actually turns out that we reject ourselves a lot more and we naturally close ourselves off from dating.
当然，第二个发现是，如果参与者报告了长期约会倦怠的迹象、症状和指标，这种情况更有可能发生。在我们转向探讨为什么这种情况往往会发生之前，还有另外几个迹象。另一个非常重要的指标是，如果你已经开始考虑余生都保持单身意味着什么。如果这个场景经常在你的脑海中播放，尽管你并不希望它是真的，这就是那个重要的区别。如果你带着快乐和积极的心态去思考余生单身这件事……
And the secondary finding, of course, was that this is more likely to be the case if the participant was reporting signs, symptoms, indicators of long-term dating burnout. Here are a couple other signs before we move on to exactly why this tends to happen. Another really important indicator is if you have started contemplating what would really mean to be single for the rest of your life. If that is a scenario that is regularly playing through your head, even though you don't want it to be the case, so that's the important distinction. if you're thinking about being single for the rest of your life with joy and a positive outlook
并且觉得，是的，其实我很喜欢这个想法，而且你根本没有在约会。我不认为这是约会倦怠的迹象。我认为这几乎是对你所处位置的接受，也是对你未来想要的接受。但如果你面临着这种拉扯，这种推拉，这种纠结——我只想扔掉约会软件。我不想再见任何人了。我打算永远一个人。
and being like, yeah, actually, I love that idea and you're not dating at all. I don't think that's a sign of dating burnout. I think that's a sign of almost maybe acceptance of where you're at and acceptance of what you want from your future. But if you are facing this like pull and push, this like tug between, I just want to ditch the dating apps. I don't want to see anyone ever again. I'm just going to be alone forever.
然后，你知道，第二周又重新下载了应用，这感觉就像是一个会让人上瘾的循环。这是约会倦怠的迹象。这表明你不断地被找到某人的希望所吸引，但随后又立即感到失望，因为你已经精疲力竭了。把它和职场倦怠做个比较……
and then, you know, the next week, readdownloading the apps, it almost feels like an addictive cycle. That is a sign of dating burnout. That is a sign that you keep being drawn back into the promise of maybe finding someone, but then immediately disappointed because you are burnt out. Think about it in comparison to a workplace burnout
或者我们通常想到的职业困境中的倦怠。当我们看到那里的倦怠时，会发生什么呢？人们会请假一天。他们会对工作感到非常非常沮丧。他们的老板会说，行吧，就请一天假吧。然后他们可能会回来工作几天，接着又立刻回到压力之中，并觉得那一天的假、那段休息时间对他们完全没有起作用。
or burnout in a professional situation where we typically think about it. When we see burnout there, what will happen is that people will take, you know, a day off. They'll be really, really stressed with work. Their boss will be like, no, just take a day off. And then they'll come back for maybe a couple of days and immediately step right back into the stress and feel like that day off, that time off did absolutely nothing for them.
因为实际上，他们并没有治疗他们的倦怠。他们只是治疗了一些症状。约会对吧也是如此。关于这种对永久单身状态的思考，对吧，其实感觉相当有可能。这感觉像是一个潜在的场景，特别是在你二十多岁和三十岁出头的时候，文化已经向非一夫一妻制或缺乏承诺发生了转变。你可以从新词汇的发明中看出这一点，比如炮友（friends with benefits）、“situationship”（处于暧昧关系中），相比于前几代人那种“好吧，只有三件事：要么单身，要么约会，要么结婚”的关系，现在的关系有更多灰色地带。在那些时代，这三种状态之间的转换可能只需要一两年。
Because actually, they didn't treat their burnout. They just treated some of the symptoms. Same goes for dating. And the thing about this contemplation of a permanent singlehood status, right, is that it actually feels quite likely. It feels like this is a potential scenario, especially in your 20s and your early 30s where there has been a cultural shift towards non-monogamy or towards a lack of commitment. You can see that in the invention of new phrases like friends with benefits, like situationships where there is more of a gray area when it comes to relationships compared to in previous generations where it was like, all right, there's three things. or either single, dating or married. And the shift, the movement between those three things probably takes around a year or two.
当然，我认为这种趋势的转变在某些方面可能是非常健康的。你知道，这表明我们不只是和遇到的第一个人结婚，然后在接下来的60年里忍受一段或许并不幸福的生活。但这是真的。这一代人对承诺的倾向更低、更少。2023年的一项研究发现，千禧一代和Z世代，我们寻找一夫一妻制或声明一夫一妻制或承诺是我们的顶级约会优先级之一的可能性要小得多。因此，这种思考——“我会不会永远单身”，也许还有对这一点的恐惧和恐慌感，但随之而来的是当你试图通过约会来抵消这种感觉时的失望感，这是约会倦怠的一个大迹象。只是筋疲力尽，感到厌烦，你厌倦了跟朋友讲你的第一次约会，你厌倦了不得不每天晚上都盛装打扮。这并不令人兴奋。那么为什么会发生这种情况呢？好吧，我们简短地讨论过这一点，我们经历约会倦怠的最大原因是因为由于寻找伴侣的压力，我们继续把自己置于一个无法满足的境地。我们的社会过度投资并将浪漫爱置于任何其他事物之上。它永远是核心。所以这意味着，当你没有约会时，你有点觉得自己……
Of course, I think the trend away from that is probably very healthy in some ways. You know, it indicates that we aren't just marrying the first person that we meet and then enduring perhaps an unhappy situation for the next 60 years. But it's true. There is a lower, lesser tendency towards commitment in this generation. And a 2023 study found that millennials and Gen Z, we are much less likely to be looking for monogamy or to state that monogamy or commitment are one of our top dating priorities. So this contemplation of like, am I maybe going to be single forever and perhaps a
你可能在让社会失望。觉得这应该是你拥有的一项优先事项。所以不这么做意味着你在落后，意味着你在错失机会。也许其中存在FOMO（害怕错过）的元素，所以你继续这样做，你继续去进行那些糟糕的约会，你继续几乎只是把脚趾伸进水里，即使你宁愿不想弄湿，因为存在着寻找伴侣的期望和压力。我们还会经历约会倦怠，因为不断结识新朋友，特别是那些你必须考虑其潜在可能或思考他们作为伴侣或配偶潜力的那些人，这在情感上消耗极大，特别是如果你没有精力（spoons），或者如果你内向的话。
almost like fear of that and a sense of panic, but then also a sense of disappointment when you try and counteract that by dating, that's a big sign of dating burnout. Just being exhausted, being tired, you're sick of telling your friends about your first dates, you're sick of going, you know, having to get dressed up every single night. It's not exciting. So why does this happen? Well, we've talked about this briefly, but the biggest reason that we experience dating burnout is because we continue to put ourselves in a situation that is not fulfilling because of this pressure to find someone. Our society overly invests and places a huge preference on romantic love over anything else. It is always at the center. So what that means is that when you are not dating, you kind of feel like
天哪，约会真是一笔时间投资。真的，这是一笔惊人的时间投资。即使你一周只去一次约会，一个月一次，那仍然可能是三到四个小时的准备时间、到达那里的时间、不得不和某人交谈的时间。我不知道在我生活中的某些时期，我甚至是否有那么多时间留给我最亲密的几个朋友。你知道，必须把约会塞进拥有一个充实社交生活、有爱好、和家人聊天、确保自己在工作、经营副业的日程里……
you're letting maybe society down. Like this is a priority that you should be having. And so not doing it means that you're falling behind, means that you're losing out. Maybe there is an element of phomo there and so you continue to do so you continue to go on the bad dates you continue to be kind of like almost just dipping your toe in the water even though you would prefer not to get wet because there is this expectation and pressure to find someone we also experience dating burnout because meeting new people constantly especially people where you kind of have to contemplate a potential or think about their potential as a mate or as a partner that is incredibly emotionally draining especially especially if you don't have the spoons or if you're introverted.
照顾好自己。这可真难。所以，当感觉我们盘子里的其他东西已经堆满了，然而我们却在这里约会，感觉自己就像是在不断地把一块重石推上山却没有成功，不可避免地，我们对这种状况会感到相当疲惫。最后，我认为约会之所以……约会倦怠之所以发生，是因为你见到的每一个人，你都必须保持在线状态，但同时也有压力要表现得像某个人，表现出你最好的一面。你得记住，你知道，无论你对它投入多少，约会确实感觉stakes（赌注）相当高。就像，你知道，你的下一个约会对象，那可能是你的灵魂伴侣。所以有一种真正的感觉……
Oh my God, dating is such a time investment. Like, it is an incredible time investment. Even if you're only going on like one day a week, one day a month, that can still be three to four hours of getting ready, of getting there, of having to talk to someone. I don't know if I even have that much time for some of my closest friends at times in my life. You know, having to fit in dating with having a fulfilling social life. having hobbies, talking to your family, making sure that you're working, running your side hustle,
当你出现时，你必须付出全部。有时这也带来了很大的压力。我一直在用“压力”这个词。你对自己设定了一个期望，要真正完美地出现，要真正给人留下深刻印象并保持在线，也许要有点虚假，因为他们可能更喜欢那个版本的你。不断这样做需要消耗大量精力，为每个月、每年涌现的新人这样做。这一切最终都会付出代价。当然，它主要在情感上付出代价，因为这就像你宁愿为自己保护的所有能量都被抽干了一样，而且如果你没有电量，没有时间，如果你没有认知资源投入到这件事中，它在身体和社交上也会付出代价。
taking care of yourself. Now that is hard. And so when it feels like the rest of our plate is already stacked up with things, and yet here we are dating and feeling like we're just constantly pushing this heavy rock up a hill with no success, inevitably we're going to feel pretty fatigued by that situation. Finally, I think dating best, we're just, dating, burnout occurs because with each new person you meet, you do have to be on, but there is also this pressure to come off as a certain person, to come off as your best self. You've got to remember, you know, dating regardless of your investment in it, still does feel like it has quite high stakes. Like, you know, the next date you go on, that could be your soulmate. And so there is a real sense
所以，这基本上把我们引向了倦怠的点，引向了那种感到完全被冷落、失望、沮丧，但几乎又觉得你必须继续参与这项活动以满足社会的期望或为了得到你想要的东西的地方。就像你想要被爱。为什么得到它的过程感觉如此折磨人？它不必是那样的。这就是我今天对你的郑重承诺。约会不一定非得感觉像个苦差事。它不必感觉像是一种惩罚或监狱。它可以是有趣的。你可以把快乐、火花和兴奋带回来……
that when you show up, you have to be giving everything. And sometimes that creates a lot of pressure as well. I keep using the word pressure. You place an expectation on yourself to really show up perfectly and to really be impressive and to be on, maybe to be a little bit fake because they might like that version of you more. That takes a lot of energy to do that constantly, to do that for a slew of new people every month, every year. It all ends up taking its toll. of course it takes its toll primarily emotionally because it's just kind of like all this energy that you would rather protect for yourself as being leached out, but also like physically and
带回到它里面。所以我想在短暂的休息之后讨论如何应对约会倦怠，以及如何在约会生活中取得更多成功。2%。这就是当有自动扶梯可用时，仍然选择走楼梯的人的比例。我是迈克尔·伊斯特，在我的播客《2%》中，我将剖析精神坚韧度、体能训练以及在我们这个奇怪的现代世界中建立韧性的科学。我将与作家、研究人员以及其他健康和健身专家等进行对话，看透主导健康产业的不切实际且过于复杂的伪科学。我们真的相信种子油本质上会引起炎症。
socially if you don't have the battery, you don't have the time, if you don't have the resources cognitively to invest in this. So that is basically what leads us to a point of burnout to that place of just feeling completely dejected, disappointed, frustrated, but almost feeling like you have to continue participating in this activity in order to be meeting society's expectations or in order to get the thing that you want. Like you want to be loved. Why does the process in order to get there feel so grueling? It doesn't have to feel that way. And that is my big promise to you today. Dating does not have to feel like a chore. It doesn't have to feel like a punishment or a prison. It can be fun. You can bring the joy and the spark and the excitement. And the excitement.
我们弄错了。我们在世界上惊慌失措的许多问题都是压力的结果。经历一些艰难困苦，你就会在另一端成为一个更快乐、更充实、更健康的人。在I-Hart无线电应用、苹果播客或任何你获取播客的地方收听《2%》。名字叫T-W-O-P-P-Sent。你还记得黛安娜·罗斯在VMA颁奖典礼上双击小金的胸部吗？
back into it. So I want to talk about how to counteract dating burnout and how to actually be more successful in your dating life after this short break. 2%. That is the number of people who take the stairs when there is also an escalator available. I'm Michael Easter and on my podcast 2%. I break down the science of mental toughness, fitness and building resilience in our strange modern world. I'll be speaking with writers, researchers, and other health and fitness experts, and more, to look past the impractical and way too complex pseudoscience that dominates the wellness industry. We really believe that seed oils were inherently inflammatory.
或者当坎耶说乔治·布什不关心黑人时。我知道你在想什么。乔治·布什跟小金到底有什么关系？好吧，你可以在《回味过去》播客中找到答案。我是萨姆·杰特。我是亚历克斯·英格ish。每一集，我们都会挑选一个年份，剖析发生了什么，并试图理解我们是如何熬过这段经历的。包括最近一集与马克·拉蒙特·希尔的访谈，畅谈80年代的霹雳可卡因。
We got it wrong. Many of the problems that we are freaked out about in the world are the result of stress. Put yourself through some hardships, and you will come out on the other side a happier, more fulfilled healthier person. Listen to 2%. That's TWO% on the I-Hart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Do you remember when Diana Ross double-tapped Little Kim's boobs at the VMAs?
坦白讲，84对我来说意义重大，不仅仅是因为霹雳可卡因。我随时都可以谈论霹雳可卡因，只是想让你们都知道。我的意思是，马克，这已经是我们讨论霹雳可卡因的第二集了。所以我开始看出其中有一条贯穿始终的主线。我们现在还把艾滋病摆在了台面上。谢谢你把话说完。是的。我不认为对黑人来说还有比这更重要的年份了。
Or when Kanye said that George Bush didn't like black people. I know what you're thinking. What the hell does George Bush got to do with Little Kim? Well, you can find out on the Look Back at it podcast. I'm Sam Jett. And I'm Alex English. Each episode, we pick it here, unpack what went down, and try to make sense of how we survived it. Including a recent episode with Mark Lamont Hill, waxing all about crack in the 80s.
真的吗？是的。对我来说，这是美国历史上对黑人而言最重要的年份之一。在IHeart Radio应用、苹果播客或你获取播客的任何地方收听《Look Back at It》。欢迎来到我的新播客《以硬核方式去学习》，我是你的主持人、你最喜欢的治疗师凯尔·盖恩斯。为了庆祝心理健康意识月，我带来了自己在心理健康领域十多年的经验，以及与众多杰出嘉宾的对话。我说的是，特里普·方丹，瑞安·克拉克。有时，当我们追求某样东西时，我们太过于沉迷于追逐本身，以至于没有意识到我们其实已经拥有了它。
To be clear, 84 is big to me, not just because of crack. I'm down to talk about crack on day, but just so y'all know. I mean, at this point, Mark, this is the second episode where we've discussed crack, so I'm starting to see that there's a through line. We also have AIDS on the table right now, so. Thank you for finishing that sentence. Yes. I don't think there's a more important year for black people.
而我们仍在追逐。并且不知道什么时候才算足够。因为人们都在盯着记分牌。生活变成了关于输赢的较量。史蒂夫·伯恩斯，达斯汀·罗斯，因为你觉得在世期间做一个好人很重要。还是你做一个好人是因为你害怕？因为那是两种不同的动机，兄弟。绝对是。
Really? Yeah. For me, it's one of the most important years for black people in American history. Listen to look back at it on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Welcome to my new podcast, Learn the Hard Way with me, your host, and your favorite therapist, Kear Games. And in recognition of mental health awareness month, I'm bringing over a decade of my own experience in the mental health field and conversations with so many incredible guests. I'm talking, Tripp Fontaine, Ryan Clark. Sometimes when we're in the pursuit of the thing, we get so wrapped up in the chase that we don't realize that we are in possession of the thing.
那是两个不同层面的信任。我希望你能够真正地做一个好人。加入我凯尔·盖恩斯的行列，我们在我的新播客《以硬核方式去学习》中，就疗愈、成长、父爱、压力和目标展开真实的对话。打开你免费的iHeartRadio应用。搜索《Learn the Hardway》并立即收听。2023年，前《单身汉》明星克莱顿·埃克德发现自己处于父权丑闻的中心。随后的家庭法庭听证会揭露了她故事中显而易见的矛盾之处。这引发了一场长达数年的法庭之战来证明真相。你……森女士，你曾两次篡改了这个特定的测试，对吗？
And we're still chasing it. And we don't know when we've done enough. Because people scoreboard watch. Life becomes about wins and losses. Steve Burns, Dustin Ross, because you find it important to be a good person while you hear on Earth. Are you a good person because you're afraid? Because that's two different intentions, bro. Absolutely.
我们仍在追逐它，而且我们不知道什么时候才算足够。因为人们在看记分牌。生活成了关于输赢的事情。史蒂夫·伯恩斯、达斯汀·罗斯，因为你们觉得在地球上做一个好人很重要。你是因为害怕才做一个好人吗？因为这是两种不同的动机，兄弟。绝对是。
And that's two different levels of trust. I want you to just really be a good person. person. Join me, Keir Gaines, as we have real conversations about healing, growth, fatherhood, pressure, and purpose on my new podcast, Learn the Hardway. Open your free iHeartRadio app. Search Learn the Hardway and listen now. In 2023, former bachelor star Clayton Eckerd found himself at the center of a paternity scandal. The family court hearings that followed revealed glaring inconsistencies in her story. This began a years-long court battle to prove the truth. You I doctored this particular test twice in so-ins, correct?
而且这是两个不同层面的信任。我希望你真正成为一个好人。加入我，基尔·盖恩斯，在我的新播客《吸取教训》中，我们进行关于治愈、成长、为人父、压力和目标的真实对话。打开你免费的 iHeartRadio 应用。搜索《吸取教训》并立即收听。在2023年，前《单身汉》明星克莱顿·埃克德发现自己处于一场父权丑闻的中心。随后的家庭法庭听证会揭露了他故事中明显的矛盾之处。这开始了长达数年的法庭之争，以证明真相。你，我伪造了这个特定的测试两次，对吗？
I doctored the test ones. It took an army of internet detectives to crack the case. I wanted people to be able to see what their tax dollars were being used for. Sunlight's the greatest disinfected. They would uncover a disturbing pattern. Two more men who'd been through the same thing. Gregalespian and Michael Marantini. My mind was blown.
我篡改了测试结果。这需要一大群网络侦探来破解这个案子。我希望人们能看到他们的税都被用在了哪里。阳光是最好的消毒剂。他们会发现一个令人不安的模式。另外两个经历过同样事情的男人。格雷格·莱斯皮安和迈克尔·马拉蒂尼。我的大脑彻底被震撼了。
I'm Stephanie Young. This is Love Trap. Laura, Scottsdale Police. As the season continues, Laura Owens finally faces consequences. Ladies and gentlemen, breaking news at Americopa County as Laura Owens has been indicted on fraud charges. This isn't over until justice is served in Arizona. Listen to Love Trapped podcast on the Iheart radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts.
我是斯蒂芬妮·杨。这是《爱情陷阱》。劳拉，斯科茨代尔警察。随着节目的继续，劳拉·欧文斯终于面临后果。女士们先生们，亚美利科帕县的突发新闻，劳拉·欧文斯因欺诈罪被起诉。在亚利桑那州伸张正义之前，这一切都不会结束。在Iheart电台应用程序、苹果播客或您获取播客的任何地方收听《陷入爱河》播客。
I really think that if you're struggling with this at the moment, if you just feel like every day you go on is a dud, every person is disappointing you. it never works out it's not you it is the entire culture of dating that has made it feel very transactional very fast very convenient and ultimately disappointing so i really reached this point um probably like two and a half years ago where it had just been like back to back situationships back to back you know four to five date situations where you're just about to get your hopes up and You're like, yay, maybe I, like, have met my person and no, I have not. And you're disappointed it. You're let down it again yet again.
我真的认为，如果你此刻正在为此苦苦挣扎，如果你只是觉得你度过的每一天都很无聊，每个人都让你失望，事情从来没有成功过，那不是你的问题，而是整个约会文化让它感觉非常具有交易性、非常快、非常方便，最终令人失望。所以我真的到了这个点，大概是在两年半前，当时就像是一个接一个的恋爱局，一个接一个的，你知道的，四到五次的约会，你正准备抱有希望，然后你想，耶，也许我，就像，遇到了我的真命天子/真命天女，不，我没有。你对此感到失望。你又一次被抛弃了。
And, you know, there is this almost like emotional vulnerability hangover for a couple of weeks. And then you're like, no, I'm not going to let this get me down. I want to find love. So I'm going to get back out there. And the cycle repeats itself. I found that I was getting, I was way too attached to the people that I was matching with or the people that I was meeting because in them, there was this whole great future that they could unlock.
而且，你知道，有那么几周，几乎就像有一种情感脆弱的宿醉。然后你会想，不，我不会让这把我击垮。我想找到爱。所以我打算重新开始。这个循环就会重复。我发现自己变得，我对和我匹配的人或我遇到的人产生了太多的依恋，因为在他们身上，有一个他们可以解锁的伟大的未来。
You know, if they were the one, suddenly all my woes with dating would be over. I would be kind of able to tick this off my list. I could rest easy. I would have love and great. I had done the thing that I needed to do. And I just had this epiphany that that was the complete incorrect attitude. It was the incorrect attitude because anyone could come along and be let straight through the door into my heart, into my life.
你知道，如果他们就是那个人，突然间我所有的约会烦恼都会结束。我差不多可以把这从我的清单上勾掉了。我可以高枕无忧了。我会拥有爱情和美好。我已经做完了我需要做的事情。我突然顿悟到，这完全是错误的态度。这是错误的态度，因为任何人都可以出现，并且被直接放进我的心里，进入我的生活。
because I was so done with being single and I was so sick of dating. This is what I did. I did a complete six-month hiatus. Previously, I had tried to do this, but I would, you know, get in like a couple of weeks and then I'd read-download the apps or I would like find myself flirting with someone or going on like a couple of dates and it was right back to the beginning. So I made a promise. I said, I'm going to give myself six months to not talk to anyone.
因为我对单身感到厌倦，我也对约会感到厌倦。这就是我所做的。我进行了整整六个月的暂停。以前，我曾尝试过这样做，但是，你知道，我会坚持几周，然后我又会重新下载应用程序，或者我发现自己和某人调情，或者去约会几次，然后又回到了原点。所以我许下一个承诺。我说，我要给自己六个月的时间不和任何人说话。
on a romantic sense. Even if someone happens to come along during that time, actually we're going to have a real hard line that no, the door is not open, the heart is not open. This is a time for me to reprogram and really dig around in my brain and dig around in my heart as to why I've become very susceptible to this way of dating and this sense of rejection and disappointment. So I started and I did six months successfully of no dating, complete dating hiatus, a dating detox. And it was really, really hard, especially since I'd spent my entire adult life, always like going on dates and being like present romantically. That was a huge component of my social life and who I was. But I found that it was incredibly freeing. It was incredibly freeing and it made me realize how reliant I was on the
在浪漫的意义上。即使在此期间碰巧有人出现，实际上我们也会有一条明确的底线，不，大门没有敞开，心也没有敞开。这段时间是为了让我重新编程，真正深入我的大脑，深入我的内心，了解为什么我会变得非常容易受到这种约会方式以及这种拒绝和失望感的影响。所以我开始了，我成功地进行了六个月的无约会，彻底的约会暂停，一次约会排毒。这真的，真的很难，特别是自从我度过了整个成年生活，总是喜欢去约会并在浪漫方面在场。那是我的社交生活和我作为谁的一个巨大组成部分。但我发现它是无比自由的。它是无比自由的，它让我意识到我是多么依赖
validation of these people to get me through the day and to ensure that I was confident and assertive and that I felt good about myself. And suddenly when I no longer had that source of validation as simple and shallow as that validation was, I had to really get deeper and I had to become more of my own best friend and more of my own lover. And I know that sounds quite strange, like I was my own lover, but I really was for that six month period. And then guess what happened? Almost like clockwork. I finished the six-month dating hiatus.
这些人的认可来度过每一天，并确保我是自信的、果断的、我对自己的感觉很好。突然间，当我不再拥有那种认可的源泉时，无论那种认可多么简单和肤浅，我都必须真正深入挖掘，我必须成为我自己的最好朋友和更多我自己的爱人。我知道这听起来很奇怪，就像我是我自己的爱人，但在那六个月里我确实是。然后你猜怎么着？几乎像钟表一样准时。我完成了六个月的约会暂停期。
I think I met someone like two weeks later. I think I met someone. Not someone I met like the love of my life. I met the man that I am still with. It's been like a year and a half. We're still together. We're so, so strong. And I'm not saying that it was my period of my dating hiatus that led me there.
我想我大约两周后遇到了某人。我想我遇到了某人。不是我遇到了我一生的挚爱。我遇到了我现在仍然和在一起的那个男人。已经一年半了。我们依然在一起。我们非常，非常坚强。我并不是说正是我的约会暂停期把我带到了那里。
What I am saying is that it was. my change in attitude. It wasn't that I suddenly came back and there was all these more, more options. No, it was that I came into it with a much more relaxed attitude, a much more relaxed state of mind. And it meant that I was more authentic when I did actually meet Tom, my partner, I was more authentic. And I didn't get attached and put so much pressure on the early days of our relationship, which meant that it was actually able to blossom. And we actually were able to form a connection that wasn't based on this real fear factor for me or this real loneliness factor. It was organic, although, you know, we did meet on a dating app. Like, it felt like the connection was not
我要说的是，是我的态度改变了。并不是说我突然回来，有所有这些更多的选择。不，是我以一种更放松的态度、更轻松的心态进入这段关系。这意味着当我真正遇到汤姆，我的伴侣时，我更真实，我更真实。我没有产生依恋，也没有给我们的关系早期施加太大的压力，这意味着它实际上能够绽放。我们实际上能够建立一种联系，这种联系不是基于我真正的恐惧因素或真正的孤独因素。它是机缘巧合的，虽然，你知道，我们确实是在约会软件上认识的。就像，感觉这种联系不是
artificial. The other component of this was that I really actually had fun. I did go on like some dates with other people around that time and it was fun. It was fun. It was. It was. fun and it was easy to be like, no, I don't want to see you again or like, yeah, why not? Without me being like, okay, is this the one contemplating the wedding? And so I think also that six month period or however long you would like to take is also the time that if we were considering burnout in a normal sense is probably the timeline that most of us would be on. Six to months to a year, I would say that is how long it takes to recover from normal burnout. Because you really have to completely heal and rejuvenate and poor energy and poor love back into
人工的。这的另一个部分是我真的玩得很开心。在那段时间里，我确实和别的一些人去约会了，这很有趣。这很有趣。这确实。很有趣，而且很容易说，不，我不想再见到你了，或者，是的，为什么不呢？而不需要我去想，好吧，这是那个人吗，在考虑婚礼。所以我也认为那六个月的时间，或者你愿意花多长时间，也是如果我们从正常意义上考虑倦怠，可能是我们大多数人所处的时间线。六个月到一年，我会说这需要多长时间从正常的倦怠中恢复过来。因为你真的必须完全治愈和恢复活力，并将能量和爱倾注回
the places in which these resources have been depleted by your situation. The other thing that I think really helps us get over dating burnout is to take a step back firstly and really focus on what you're looking for. What do you actually want? Not every single person that you're going to come across deserves a, first date, to be honest, deserves a first message. You cannot see the potential in people from a profile or from a first meeting and expect them to follow on with that potential and to completely fulfill it based on your expectations. You've got to trust that the first, not the first thing
你的情况耗尽了这些资源的那些地方。我认为真正有助于我们克服约会倦怠的另一件事是首先退后一步，真正专注于你在寻找什么。你到底想要什么？老实说，并不是你遇到的每个人都值得约会，都值得一条第一条消息。你不能从个人资料或第一次见面中看到人们的潜力，并期望他们以这种潜力继续发展，并完全根据你的期望来实现它。你必须相信第一，不是第一件事
you see of them, but the information that they give you initially is the truth. So if you are looking at a dating profile and this person just looks a bit often, it says, you know, um, not looking for monogamy. Oh, I like, I drink a lot and you don't. Or like, oh, yeah, I live here and it's quite far from you. But all you're seeing is potential. You're going to be like, yeah, okay, I'll go on a date with this person and you're going to make time for them in your day. You're going to make time for them in your week and they are going to be disappointing. And then you're going to look at yourself and be like, what's wrong with me? Like, what's wrong with me? Nothing. Nothing is wrong with you. Nothing is wrong with you other than that. Perhaps you need to reconsider why it is that you are allowing these
你看到的他们，但他们最初给你的信息是真相。因此，如果你正在看一个约会资料，这个人看起来有点不对劲，上面写着，你知道，嗯，不寻求一夫一妻制。哦，我喜欢，我喝很多酒而你不喝。或者，哦，是的，我住在这里，离你挺远。但你看到的只有潜力。你会想，是的，好吧，我会和这个人约会，你会在你的一天中为他们腾出时间。你会在你的星期里为他们腾出时间，他们会让人失望。然后你会看着自己，心想，我怎么了？就像，我怎么了？没事。你什么事都没有。你什么事都没有，除了
people to come into your life because in those interactions where they are on a date with you, they are talking to you, they are with you, present with you, that is taking something from you that is taking, you know, a part of you that could have been expended elsewhere, that could have been used elsewhere, a part of your day that could have been invested elsewhere. So I want you right now, if you are actively dating, to really sit down and write five things that you absolutely definitely want in a partner. Five things that really matter to you that you will not compromise on. And if you can't think of five things, that might be a problem, that might be indicative that actually, you know, you're not picky enough. I think each person
也许你需要重新考虑为什么你要允许这些人进入你的生活，因为在那些互动中，他们和你约会，他们和你说话，他们和你在一起，和你在一起，这从你身上带走了一些东西，这带走了，你知道，你可以用在别处的一部分自己，可以花在别处的一部分，你的一天中可以投资在别处的部分。所以我现在希望你，如果你在积极约会，真正坐下来写下五件你在伴侣身上绝对肯定想要的东西。五件对你真正重要且你绝不妥协的事情。如果你想不出五件事，那可能是一个问题，这可能表明实际上，你知道，你还不够挑剔。我认为每个人
should have at least five deal breakers. Otherwise, again, you get into that scenario that I was very much in. So this isn't, I really hope this isn't coming off, it's coming from a place of judgment, but I myself was in that position where I had two things that I was like, yeah, this is a deal breaker. But it actually meant that, you know, the fishing net was quite wide when really I needed to be using a fishing pole and going selectively for certain people who I know I would be quite compatible with. So get clear on what you want. Take the pressure off by taking a break. Those in my first two steps. I also think that when you go on a bad date when something doesn't work out, don't let it ruin your perspective on everything. Don't let it be the defining experience for you.
应该至少有五个雷区。否则，你会再次陷入我当时非常处于的那个场景。所以这不是，我真的希望这听起来不是在评判，但我自己就处于那种状态，我有两件事我觉得，是的，这是一个雷区。但这实际上意味着，你知道，渔网相当大，而实际上我需要用鱼竿，有选择地针对某些我知道我会非常合得来的人。所以弄清楚你想要什么。通过休息来减轻压力。这些是我前两步。我还认为，当你去了一次糟糕的约会，当事情没有成功时，不要让它毁了你对一切的看法。不要让它成为你的决定性体验。
Something that really helped me because, you know, rejection does happen in this like cutthroat dating world, something that really helped me build my resilience because you need a whole lot of resilience if you're dating in this decade, was to have statements that I would repeat to myself after something didn't work out. One of the ones I remember using was, I am love, so love will find me, but it's not all that defines me. I am love, so love will find me, but it's not all that defines me. And that was really, really important and valuable. I also did affirmations of like, I attract beautiful people because I am a beautiful person. The love I pour into others will be poured back into myself. What were some others? Some, oh, you know, just small things,
真正对我有帮助的事情，因为，你知道，在这个残酷的约会世界里确实会发生拒绝，真正帮助我建立韧性的事情，因为如果你在这个十年约会，你需要大量的韧性，就是在事情没有成功后我会对自己重复的语句。我记得我用过的一句话是，我是爱，所以爱会找到我，但这并不是定义我的全部。我是爱，所以爱会找到我，但这并不是定义我的全部。这真的，真的很重要也很有价值。我还做了这样的肯定，我吸引美好的人，因为我是一个美好的人。我倾注给别人的爱将倾注回我自己身上。还有哪些？一些，哦，你知道，只是一些小事，
Like someone's inability to see my value doesn't mean that it's not there. That was a great one. And also it was very validating to remind myself that there are so many people in this world, it is impossible for me to be, and for you, to go about your life and not eventually encounter someone who thinks you're freaking amazing. And if you have an open heart, if you're not burnt out, if you're actually excited about the prospect, if you know what you want, if you know what you want, not. what the other person wants, you know what you want. That might actually be exactly what you need.
就像别人无法看到我的价值并不意味着它不存在。这是一个很棒的观点。提醒自己，这个世界上有这么多人，我和你不可能在度过一生时，最终遇不到一个认为你棒极了的人，这也非常具有肯定作用。如果你有一颗开放的心，如果你没有精疲力竭，如果你对这个前景真的很兴奋，如果你知道你想要什么，如果你知道你想要什么，而不是。别人想要什么，你知道你想要什么。这可能正是你所需要的。
It might be where the spark really catches when you're prepared. Finally, I really want you to let go of the timeline. As I said at the very beginning of this episode, many people, consciously or unconsciously, subscribe to an internal dating timeline. You want to meet someone by 25, get engaged by 28, get married by 30, etc., etc. that timeline, which feels imposed on all of us, is arbitrary. It's actually a social construct. And it's very detrimental to your dating success. Anytime we place these concrete limits on ourselves, however they may look, we also place limits on our sense of curiosity, our sense of fun or excitement, not just when it comes to love, but when it comes to anything, when it starts to feel like a job or it starts to feel like
这可能是当你们都准备好时火花真正点燃的地方。最后，我真的希望你放下时间线。正如我在本集开头所说的那样，许多人有意识或无意识地认同内在的约会时间线。你想在25岁之前遇到某人，在28岁之前订婚，在30岁之前结婚，等等，等等。这条时间线，感觉强加在我们所有人身上，是武断的。它实际上是一个社会建构。这对你的约会成功非常有害。每当我们对自己设定这些具体的限制时，无论它们看起来如何，我们也会限制我们的好奇心、我们的乐趣或兴奋感，不仅在爱情方面，在任何事情上，当它开始像一份工作或开始感觉像
there is something restricting our freedom within that space. Suddenly it's a task that needs to be completed or ticked off. It's something that is very rigid and very defined and inflexible. And so that becomes a lot less enjoyable. It's like when you have a hobby or like a creative skill or something that you really love doing, as soon as that becomes like a job, as soon as you feel like you have to do it, that all the enjoyment gets sucked out pretty quickly. So see the timeline, acknowledge the timeline, acknowledge that people are going to perhaps, I don't know, still try and enforce the timeline on you. And remind yourself that there are a lot of people who do not meet that timeline and still have very fulfilling deep love who still have all the things that they enjoy and love and deserve and wanted from life. And that there is no one way of going about this.
在这个空间内有什么东西限制了我们的自由。突然间，它成了一项需要完成或勾选的任务。这是非常死板、非常明确且不灵活的。因此，这变得不那么令人愉快了。就像当你有一个爱好或某种创造性的技能或你真正喜欢做的事情时，一旦它变成了一份工作，一旦你觉得你不得不这样做，所有的乐趣就会很快被吸干。所以看到时间线，承认时间线，承认人们可能会，我不知道，仍然试图将时间线强加给你。并提醒自己，有很多人并没有达到那个时间线，却依然拥有非常充实的深厚爱情，依然拥有他们从生活中享受、热爱、应得和想要的一切。并且没有一种单一的方法来处理这件事。
There is not one particular version of love and dating and the transition from first meet to, you know, forever together that looks the same. So when you're thinking about whoever you're comparing yourself to, because we all do, remember that it's going to look differently for you. Date because you really want to date. Date because you are excited and curious and you want to meet new people. release yourself from this pressure to perform to a given time frame. All of this will actually help ease your anxiety and your stress. And with that, bring about much deeper and richer dating experiences, mean you have much better boundaries,
没有一种特定版本的爱情和约会，以及从初次相识到，你知道，永远在一起的转变看起来是一样的。所以当你想到你正在与之比较的任何人时，因为我们都会这样做，请记住，对你来说它看起来会是不同的。约会是因为你真的想约会。约会是因为你兴奋、好奇并且想结识新的人。从在给定的时间框架内表现的压力中解放出来。所有这些实际上都会帮助缓解你的焦虑和压力。随之而来的是更深、更丰富的约会体验，这意味着你有更好的界限，
mean that you are much more discerning. You're better able to say, yeah, actually, no, I don't want to go on a second date with you. Or, you know, actually, I really like this guy or I like this person. And even if I imagine that I'll be rejected, I'm just going to do it anyways, because I'm here to have fun, I'm here to meet great people, I'm here to have one good conversation at a time, and that is all that I'm asking from this situation. And with that, a real feeling of liberation and freedom and flexibility comes over you. So I want to say thank you for listening to this episode.
意味着你更有洞察力。你更能说，是的，其实，不，我不想和你进行第二次约会。或者，你知道，其实，我真的很喜欢这家伙或者我喜欢这个人。即使我猜想会被拒绝，我也要这么做，因为我是来寻找乐趣的，我是来结识优秀的人的，我是来一次进行一次好对话的，这就是我对这种情况的所有要求。伴随着这些，真正的解放感、自由感和灵活性油然而生。所以我想说谢谢你收听这一集。
If you are dealing with a little bit of dating burnout, the thing I recommend, once again, take a break. It's okay. it's actually going to be a really great investment in the long run if you have energy and if you have the patience and the capacity to enjoy this experience. I'm also just sending you a lot of strength and a lot of support. Dating is freaking tough, especially in this climate, in this social context. Gosh, it's rough. So you're not alone. You are most certainly not the only one dealing with this, but most of all I can promise that you will find love.
如果你正在处理一点约会倦怠，我再次推荐的事情是，休息一下。没关系。如果你有精力、有耐心和能力去享受这段经历，从长远来看，这实际上将是一笔非常棒的投资。我也向你送去很多力量和很多支持。约会太难了，尤其是在这种气候下，在这种社会背景下。天哪，太艰难了。所以你并不孤单。你绝不是唯一一个处理这个问题的人，但最重要的是我向你保证你会找到爱。
Very simple. If you're waiting for someone to, you know, confirm that for you, done. I will confirm it. You will find love. Right now it might just not be your time. You might just be experiencing a bit of cognitive and mental exhaustion when it comes to the dating process that gets you there. But it will come eventually.
很简单。如果你在等某人，你知道，为你确认这一点，搞定。我来确认。你会找到爱。现在可能还不是你的时间。在约会过程中，你可能只是经历了一点认知和精神上的疲惫。但它最终会来的。
Just make sure you're having fun with it. As always, if you did enjoy this episode, make sure that you are following along on Spotify. Make sure that you're following us. on Instagram at That Psychology Podcast. Please feel free to give us a five-star review wherever you are listening. And yeah, if you have more episode suggestions, if you have feedback, if you have your own dating burnout experience you want to share, send us a DM. We would love to hear from you.
只要确保你在其中玩得开心。一如既往，如果你确实喜欢这一集，请确保在Spotify上关注。确保在Instagram上关注我们：@That Psychology Podcast。请随时在你收听的任何地方给我们一个五星好评。是的，如果你有更多的剧集建议，如果你有反馈，如果你有你想分享的你自己的约会倦怠经历，给我们发私信。我们很乐意听到你的声音。
And until next time, stay safe, stay kind. Please be gentle with yourself. We'll talk very, very soon. Hey, what's good, y'all? You're listening to Learn the Hardway with your favorite therapist and host Kear Games. This space is about black men's experiences, having honest conversations that it's really not safe to have anywhere, but you're having them with a licensed professional who knows what he's doing. How many men carry a suit or armor. It signals to the world that you're not to be played with.
直到下一次，保持安全，保持善良。请对自己好一点。我们很快就会再聊。嘿，最近怎么样，各位？你们正在收听的是由你最喜欢的治疗师兼主持人凯尔·盖姆斯主持的《艰难之路》。这个空间是关于黑人男性的经历，进行在任何地方都不太安全的坦诚对话，但你是和一个知道自己在做什么的持牌专业人士进行的。有多少男人带着盔甲。它向世界发出信号，你是不好惹的。
And just because you have the capability that does not mean that you need to. Listen to learn the hard way on the AHA radio app, Apple Podcast, or wherever you get your podcast. In 2023, Bachelor star Clayton Eckerd was accused of fathering twins. But the pregnancy appeared to be a hoax. You doctored this particular test twice in so-ins, correct? I doctored the test once. It took an army of internet detectives to uncover a disturbing pattern. Two more men who'd been through the same thing.
仅仅因为你有这种能力，并不意味着你需要这样做。在AHA电台应用程序、苹果播客或您获取播客的任何地方收听《艰难之路》。2023年，《单身汉》明星克莱顿·埃克德被指控是双胞胎的父亲。但这次怀孕似乎是个骗局。你把这个特定的测试篡改了两次，对吗？我篡改测试了一次。这需要一大群网络侦探来揭露一个令人不安的模式。另外两个经历过同样事情的男人。
Greg Gillespie and Michael Ranchini. My mind was blown. I'm Stephanie Young. This is love trapped. Laura, Scottsdale Police. As the season continues, Laura Owens finally faces consequences. Listen to a love-trapped podcast on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts.
格雷格·吉勒斯皮和迈克尔·兰奇尼。我的大脑彻底被震撼了。我是斯蒂芬妮·杨。这是《爱情陷阱》。劳拉，斯科茨代尔警察。随着节目的继续，劳拉·欧文斯终于面临后果。在IHeart电台应用程序、苹果播客或您获取播客的任何地方收听《陷入爱河》播客。
2%. That's the number of people who take the stairs when there is also an escalator available. I'm Michael Easter. I'm on my podcast, 2%. I break down the science of mental toughness, fitness, and building resilience in our strange modern world. Put yourself through some hardships, and you will come out on the other side, a happier, more fulfilled, healthier person. Listen to 2%.
2%。这是在也有自动扶梯可用时走楼梯的人的比例。我是迈克尔·伊斯特。在我的播客《2%》中，我剖析了我们这个奇怪的现代世界中心理韧性、健身和建立韧性的科学。让自己经历一些苦难，你就会在另一端成为一个更快乐、更满足、更健康的人。收听《2%》。
That's TWO% on the IHeartRadio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. When a group of women discover they've all dated the same prolific con artist, they take matters into their own hands. I vowed. I will be his last target. He is not going to get away with this. He's going to get what he deserves. We always say that trust your girlfriends. Listen to the girlfriends.
这是IHeartRadio应用程序、Apple Podcasts上的《2%》，或者无论你在哪里获取播客。当一群女性发现她们都和同一个多产的骗子约会过时，她们采取了行动。我发誓。我会成为他的最后一个目标。他不会逃脱惩罚的。他会得到他应得的。我们总是说相信你的女朋友们。收听《女朋友们》。
Trust me, babe, on the IHeart radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. This is an IHeart podcast. Guaranteed human. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
相信我，宝贝，在IHeart电台应用程序、苹果播客或您获取播客的任何地方收听。这是一档IHeart播客。保证真人。本集还没有评论。点击剧本中的任何句子发表评论。